Finally, after the long wait since that concert, I can finally announce something that everyone has been waiting for.
The most polygons you've ever seen!
A debut that's been anticipated for years!
My official 3D debut!
With special guests, special performances, special everything!
And the debut is... right now!
It's finally here!
Look, dragoons!
I'm 3D now!
Look at these movements!
Whoa!
That new 5090 RTX on is hitting hard.
Wait, is this not the dookie you wanted?
I mean, you can't get any more 3D than this.
I told you!
Anime girls are real!
Come on!
Look at these close-ups!
Whoa!
Look at this!
And this!
It looks like real leather!
Wait, I know.
You're expecting something else, right?
Okay, fine, fine.
I guess you dragoons deserve a real 3D debut.
It is my one-year anniversary.
Now...
What you're actually waiting for?
My real 3D debut!
That's right!
It's me!
Retro dookie!
Man, 3D graphics go hard now.
What?
Is this not the 3D debut you're looking for?
But it looks and feels so real.
I mean, if you zoom in...
You might even see some of my pores.
Oh, I see!
You wanted me in something else, right?
Like, her?
Hey, dragoons.
Is this the 3D dookie you wanted?
I mean...
I am the best dookie that everyone wants to see.
All dookie is best girl.
Just like Kathy.
Okay, okay.
Enough of her!
We don't want you to forget about me!
Look, I'm fucking with you guys.
Okay?
I know what you're here for.
Here...
Is the real 3D debut!
Doesn't get more 3D than this!
That's right!
My true form!
Tomato dookie bird!
What do you think?
Yeah?
I'm probably a little bit bigger than a regular tomato.
I think a year ago, I was this size.
All right, all right, dragoons.
No more baiting.
I'm not gonna bait anymore.
All right, you guys ready?
In 3...
2...
1...
My real 3D debut!
Oh!
Here I am.
The real dookie.
I mean...
What gets realer than this?
Well...
I hope you guys enjoyed my 3D debut!
Happy one year anniversary, dragons!
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Ca-ca!
Crook!
Real!
Crookie is real!
Oh my god!
But thank you everybody for coming to my first year anniversary!
Since I came back!
Um...
Surprise!
I guess that's all I had planned!
Ha ha ha!
I'm joking!
There's more announcements later!
Ca-ca!
Crookie out!
Bye!
Sorry!
There's no actual 3D debut!
That was just the longest beta switch I've ever done!
Bye bye!
Oh, so here's me with a cowboy hat!
Yee-haw!
Ca-ca!
Alright, bye!
I fly away now!
Woo!